let's think about where we would plot  two-thirds on this number line so first  of all let's make sure we understand  what each of these little hash marks are  we have one hash mark we're starting at  zero then we get one hash mark two hash  marks three hash marks take us all the  way to one or another way to think about  it is these hash marks have divided our  number line between zero and one into  three equal spaces so each of the  essentially it's dividing zero and  between the space between zero and one  into three so each of these are  incrementing by one third so this takes  us to one-third  then this we go another third takes us  to two-thirds and then this takes us to  three-thirds i'll write it up here which  is the exact same thing as one and so  we've already answered our question  where would we plot two over three well  it is right over there where would we  plot one over three well this is in  thirds so it would be right over there